[Music]
hello there watching the press preview a
first look then at what is on the front
pages time then to see what's making the
headlines with the guardians chief
political correspondent jessica elgot
and the chief executive of conservative
home mark wallace very good to see both
of you on a very busy day
so to the front pages then let's start
with the telegraph a hammer blow the
paper says to the prime minister's
authority the telegraph saying almost
100 conservative mps voted against uh
having covered passports or negative
tests at large events
the guardian also leading with the pm's
humiliating rebellion
the times reporting the result was far
bigger than what number 10 and the whips
expected
the financial times says tonight's
events are the biggest setback of boris
johnson's premiership
the metro calls it the pm's christmas
stuffing
while the eye proclaims omicron
threatens a normal christmas reporting
that the government is examining the
idea of even further restrictions than
those voted on in the house of commons
tonight
the daily mail leads with what it's
calling the shocking failure of social
workers and doctors after the deaths of
ella rose clover and star hobson
and the sun looks at the queen's plans
to host her family christmas party with
the headline keep calm like mom
there we go now you know uh jessica l
got mark wallace out here well what a
night um what a couple of days i guess
uh
mark first of all your reaction um you
know this big rebellion uh even the
telegraph pointing out that this is a
hammer blow to the prime minister's
authority where do you stand
well it's a remarkable moment almost two
years to the day since he won that huge
majority in the 2019 general election
now boris johnson faces a rebellion
sizably bigger than that which david
cameron faced over say any the eu
referendum votes and something that
presides
more trouble for him to come so that is
a it's a huge sign of discontent and
frustration within the conservative
party i've got to say it's also
a bit of a sign here that labour might
be getting a little bit better at
politics because by
uh
deciding to vote with the government as
the opposition did they effectively
maximize the rebellion on the government
benches they made it a free um punch
effectively for a conservative venture
he wanted to send a message about
discontent to the prime minister knowing
that labour weren't going to be voting
against there wasn't the chance of the
government losing
it arguably made it easier i suspect for
some of those mps to do that that's a
kind of savvy that you haven't seen from
the opposition for quite some time
yes and uh jessica um the guardian then
johnson suffers huge tory rebellion over
covert passes you know does it matter
what does it mean relying on labor what
does that do to your authority what's
your thoughts on this
well obviously there's a lot of
different reasons why conservative mps
might have rebelled um tonight some of
them uh want to genuinely signal their
civil liberties objections to things
like covered passports and mandatory
vaccines and for nhs workers and and
some of them just think that the way
that it's been been done is bad
law-making and some of them genuinely
just want to give johnson a kicking they
don't really like the the way the
government has handled things over the
past kind of particularly three months
and the fact that labour voted for the
government as marx
said you know gives them a free pass to
be able to send that signal i think it's
but i think that group it's particularly
interesting that the government didn't
manage to peel off that group
boris johnson made a you know kind of
emergency appearance at a 1922 a
committee meeting of all back benches
tonight where he you know he implored
them to vote with him and afterwards uh
you know as the ministers were saying
they thought they peeled off quite a lot
of the
the rebels but i i'm told that quite a
few people were pretty annoyed actually
that he seemed to dismiss some of the
christmas party stories as this kind of
media
story when they actually think it's
pretty serious and they're hearing their
constituents say they think it's pretty
serious and so so you know
they came out that i think thinking that
they'd won over quite a few people and
then to see this sundays of a rebellion
is much bigger than any of them thought
they were going to see
yeah i mean that's interesting isn't it
because after the meeting certainly the
word was that the rebellion was melting
away that the prime minister had been
very sober and serious and that's
exactly what was needed you know chris
whittie also speaking to her to some of
the rebels as well and we had the um the
all-party parliamentary group this
morning giving a sober assessment to of
omicron you know are these the very
people who have made their point today
who will melt away come january like
they did last year mark should cases of
omicron go through the roof as
anticipated
well i think as jeff says there's a
number of different issues that are that
that are at play here to a certain
extent though
obviously there's questions of the
actual um matter at hand and people may
end up with egg on their faces to to put
it mildly depending on what happens next
but there is this wider question of
authority and this wider question of um
frankly
there's all sorts of different reasons
why mps might uh
feel quite disgruntled with downing
street with their leadership at the
moment and that that has contributed to
some extent to a loss of trust it was
interesting i think to hear in the
debate various kind of slippery slope
arguments being made by people who were
concerned about this when the government
was offering reassurances that it
wouldn't go further with um one type of
restriction or another
there were several voices right saying
well what guarantees do we have of that
you know i i think there are some clear
concerns there that when ministers are
assuring backbenchers that they won't uh
build on these powers to go further
there seems to be a loss of trust in in
some quarters of the parliamentary
conservative party that that they can
actually hold to that or be held to that
yeah well many people believe further
restrictions should come in and that's
part of the problem isn't it uh the ft
going on the rebellion story too johnson
suffers biggest setback of premiership
in plan b rebellion but the eye
certainly starts to talk about whether
other measures are needed uh jessica
omicron threatens a normal christmas
plans for further restrictions are being
studied by the governments so
what kind of things would it be along
the lines of what we heard from nicolas
sturgeon today
i mean i think yes i mean i think that
obviously that that's that's begun
already for lots of people who live in
scotland that that particular build up
to the festive um period and in between
christmas and new year when you might
have expected people to be doing a lot
of socializing or seeing family members
they haven't seen in a long time that
you know nicholas surgeons asked people
to restrict themselves to three
households or they're not over over
christmas itself um and you know at the
moment it feels like the government you
know and boris johnson is pretty
determined to allow people to have a
normal christmas um but you've only got
to look at the kind of rising infection
rates to see that there are loads of
things that could that could potentially
happen even if the government doesn't
act and we're talking tonight to
businesses you know in in our paper and
and and
councils and and healthcare staff and
nhs chiefs and if and if you know if
this if these infection rates carry on
as high as they are it doesn't you know
whether whether omicron is milder or not
doesn't necessarily you know matter
people are having to be isolating for 10
days you know it could be way worse than
the pandemic that we saw in summer
because people are having to isolate
because of their infections and so all
of these things if that starts to happen
the government is going to have to do um
you know significant new inter
interventions um and you know to try and
stop
basically services falling over
yeah and that's that's the point made by
many a scientist isn't it as they looked
at the uh the modeling on this mark that
the slight sense that the mps were
discussing a bucket of water well rome
burnt i mean you know you're talking
about face masks in some settings it
won't do it will it
well there's a big part of the question
of course as we've seen um grimly before
in very various waves of this pandemic
of actually how many more doublings
effectively are already baked in even
given the lag we have in gathering data
the partial picture you have with
testing the lag you then have after
infection to hospitalization or to more
serious illness um you know a huge part
of this question is actually
you know to what extent is anybody in
westminster actually talking about the
stage that this wave is actually at you
know what the numbers currently display
is different to what's already happening
um around the country
okay well interestingly you can find out
how your mp voted uh during those three
votes in the commons today by scanning
the qr code on the screen right now so
if you want to find out how your local
mp voted then do do that coming up next
though if more restrictions are
reintroduced could we and should we see
a return of the furlough scheme for
businesses discussing that in just a
moment
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me now jessica elgott and
mark wallace welcome back to both of you
um so bottom of the front page of the
daily telegraph is the uh the small
matter of furlough for example as one of
the helps for people uh when an economy
is rocked as it is by variants like this
jessica certainly something raised by
nicolas sturgeon as well today the
implication that she'd like to go
further with her restrictions but
there's no money forthcoming uh so
what's the telegraph story about
well i think that there's that you know
this
that you know as as there's further
restrictions likely and some under
consideration we understand and i think
the telegraph has got as well
this idea of returning to table service
in pubs maybe some sort of social
distancing separations maybe you know a
curfew i think was quite unpopular and
not many people in government think it
worked but that could be one thing that
was under consideration that's under
consideration all of those things
materially affect whether hospitality
you know
pubs restaurants um can take as much
money as they did before
and if and if the government's mandating
that then it has to start
giving firms some cash to compensate and
and and so
obviously people in the treasury are
looking at this stuff but at the moment
i think hospitality is probably facing
the worst of all worlds which is you
know as we were discussing before the
break people are you know just
deciding not to go ahead with their
christmas parties deciding not to go
ahead with socializing these poor places
who are depending on christmas um trade
and not getting any support and seeing
people take matters into their own hands
yeah absolutely and this is you know the
one time of the year that some
businesses make their profit isn't it
and that's the the really tricky timing
of this uh mark the deja vu that we're
all feeling from from last year uh but
is the government relying do you think
on the sort of trimming of our own
social calendars in order to keep the
omicron variant in check or or is are
more restrictions likely and therefore
the funding that has to come with it
people going into voluntary if not
lockdown and voluntarily kind of taking
some more
care taking extra steps and changing
what they do as you stay with their
social calendar it clearly plays quite a
big part and it's already happening even
before the very first lockdown you saw
people starting to
shift to working from home or minimizing
so minimize socializing or change how
they were traveling we've all learned an
awful lot uh in the kind of painful 20
months or so since since that happened i
think you're already seeing that happen
you know that's one reason why the
government's announcement um video
already has an impact
beyond what parliament chooses uh you
know chose to decide today
the big difficulty and the hard thing in
our political culture is that you know
the one thing all politicians hate
saying is i don't know in answer to a
question but the truth is that while we
can see well we're learning more from
the scientists about what's happening
with omicron in terms of its capacity
how fast it spreads and potentially how
you know it its severity we're still
learning about that we're still learning
about it so even the kind of modeling
that you see coming out varies quite a
lot in terms of for example
this wave that's happening how long it's
likely to last and i think it's very
hard
really for people to put a precise
number on what you would do to what
extent when and for how long and
therefore how much cash you put behind
us yeah absolutely and today was the
last day that if you get covered you
could be released by christmas under the
uh 10 days of of quarantine rule but um
all of us wondering whether we can go
home uh and see our older relatives um
the sun picking up on that keep calm
like mom she is she is hosting the
family christmas dinner jessica
yes and i think that this is one of the
sort of big exceptions at least i i i
think in my social circle
um that people are really sort of
imposing a bit of a lockdown on
themselves cutting down on socializing
but i haven't heard anyone yet he sort
of talked about um cancelling christmas
or staying away from elderly relatives
at christmas i think that people are so
desperate and clearly with the royal
family is included in this to see each
other to spend time together after such
a difficult year most many of us were
separated from our families last year um
and you know found that very difficult
and this um year i think people are
really determined if they can to try and
have a normal christmas even if it is
for those couple of days and i think
especially as many people are expecting
more restrictions at christmas uh after
christmas and maybe into january so um
it feels very important to try and to
gather but you know the question is
what will that mean for for seeing
elderly relatives jessica and mark run
out of time thank you